We wait for humans to get to this planet.
They can't go through an alien side door. They can't will it into existence.
You gotta go. You gotta swim through Femara to get here.
That's the only way you got to get in because when you're born,
I don't care how clean you are when you're born.
You have few tubes bad,
and it was normal for a woman not to return to society until six weeks after the
baby.
So she would usually miss her own baby shower because after you gave birth for
six weeks, you will not come outside because you were thought to beat, uh,
dirty, both physically and morally. And I agree,
you know what it is about history. Generally,
people were stupid,
stupid and mean stupid and mean they were meaning Bubbies. I mean,
history is full of knees. I mean, bulbs slow down a little bit.
Some of the dumbest things I've heard, like even with gender, with gender stuff,
can you go to that? You have the gender. Here we go.
Look at this until fairly recently,
people believe that a baby's gender was determined at birth. Like just add,
match the dancers coming down, the birth canal.
It just gave you a Dick or a push. Like you just, just throw one in there.
So as you,
and then many theories have existed regarding as to how to control the baby sex.
So women would be encouraged to stay in bed for the weeks, leading up to birth,
to improve their odds of having a boy, which is just, I mean, that's nuts to me,
but that's what I want. That's interesting. It's like,
so I always think about that because the top scientists and doctors of the day
back then with all their, with all, they had thought that this was true.
They also thought the earth was flat. They also thought the sun,
the earth was sending the universe and the sun revolved around us.
And it's like, I wonder what we think now that 200 years. And I'll be like,
remember when they thought that like how stupid they were and like,
so what are we? I always try to think like, what are we doing now?
That's stupid. Probably thinking that Biden's going to win the election.
I agree. Yeah. You're putting people on notice. And honestly,
I'm not too sure.
After looking back to the Bible and reading certain things and looking back at
certain paintings, I'm not sure if Mary's should have actually been named Karen,
Karen, you're a new day notice. It's very interesting to me, Mary and Joseph,
how the three wise men whom only one what's black, so not,
not very culturally diverse. One was black,
white and accept their gift first before the other team members of the white
patriarchy.
And I just want to know where that was coming from because I was thinking about
this the other day,
it's like working out and getting in shape is the gayest thing we do because
we're really only doing it.
So other guys think we're good looking because women don't care at all.
Women couldn't care at all.
If you have a little bit of what you can't be 400 pounds,
but if you've got like a little bit of a gut,
but you have a good look at face and you work hard, it's like, that's fine.
But a guy will be like, Oh, look at your. But like girls don't care. Like, yeah,
it's just the guy when royalty gave birth,
it was like a public event till I know it was a public event. Look, they said,
um, when, uh, Marie Antoinette let them eat cake famous. He said in 1788,
when she gave birth,
200 people were in attendance because now would be a good time with the world
being shut down for you want to sell some tickets for your childbirth?
Absolutely. And because make no mistake, she's getting the bottom of the tank.
What your glue? Because you're 55 years old. So she's getting the glue.
That's just at the very bottom. So make them stick. The only,
the thing that I'm believing in the most and hanging my hat on the most is the
power of Mrs. Papa's is uterus is going to make that baby great.
Cause make no mistake. You gave her the bottom of the Baldridge. I mean, for me,
going to a baby shower back in the day would have been hard.
Cause I don't think they invented gift cards yet because I'm just a kid.
I just get you a gift card or a gift card type of guy, because I'm GFC,
giftcard, Chrissy guys used to do. But you know,
that's a very guy present to give gift cards.
Guys used to give his presence before gift cards. I don't know.
I honestly have no lack of cigarettes or something. Like I literally man,
like I would like for like a nice, nice, nice occasion.
Like I'll buy my mother a thousand dollars gift card. Like I don't care.
I just don't try to actively dismantle the patriarchy stop using patriarchal
terms from the past. Yeah. Let's think of new stuff. Oh, the other words,
a new word that got canceled today.
What was the new word that we saw that got canceled? Oh hilarious.
You can't say hilarious anymore. Hilarious. Toxic, hilarious. Toxic.
We're going to change our name to history. Her story. We're unnoticed. Yeah.
That's what it is. Yeah. Thank you guys so much for watching.
We hope you loved it. Don't forget to click,
subscribe and turn your alerts on it. Go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys.
For more fun where things can.
Really.